Yeah.
What's it looking like over there? What's the temp?
83 Fahrenheit right now because it's night time it's like 12 you know midnight. So at midnight it's 83 so you can imagine what's going to happen when it's like noon time.
83.
Mm.
Yeah, probably what we're getting today. It's like 98 here today.
Nice. So you went to FIFA match yesterday?
I went to I went to France versus Iraq like 2 Mondays ago. Yeah, it was.
Ohh.
Okay, so you saw Mbappe scoring.
I did. I saw him score twice. It was amazing. It was so fun. Yeah, I saw him score. I saw him score a real nice one with his left foot. Yeah, it was so cool.
He, he, he the crazy the.
He's A phenomenal player, man. I mean, he's next Messi for me. I saw him during 2022 World Cup. Yeah, and the final between Argentina and France and the way he pulled, he almost, you know, he pulled it off. So
Okay.
Yeah.
Amazing, I mean.
He almost did. You see, you saw him in person?
Yeah.
No, no, not in person. I'm not a huge... No, I wish, I wish, I wish, but yeah, I mean, I...
I thought you meant you wrote the final for a second. I was like, woo!
Me too.
Yeah, it was.
Got.
Yeah, yeah, I mean, like, I'm not a huge soccer fan, but I only watch a FIFA World Cup. That's the only thing that I watch. Apart from this, I don't watch any other, you know, like English Premier or any other league. But I mean, when I saw Mbappe, I was like blown away with the speed, with the way this guy
Yeah.
you know, maneuvers the ball and it's crazy. I just can't even, you know, as a normal human being, it's impossible for us, right?
No, it's crazy to see in person too, like just seeing him accelerate the way he does. And then they have that Alise on their team too. I think he's like the silkiest smooth player I've ever seen in my life. Like the way he just like moves with the ball and the passes he finds and like it's incredible to watch. But Mbappe is
Mhm.
Yeah.
I'm so happy I got to see him in person score. So I'm rooting for France now because I want to see, I want to say I saw the World Cup champions play in person.
The hot favorites, hot favorites, I mean, last time they were almost there, it just Messi was, you know, much better on the given day, but I mean, they are the hot favorites, trust me.
Yep.
They're gonna be, they're gonna be a tough team to beat. They're gonna be a problem.
Absolutely, absolutely, absolutely. They destroyed Sweden yesterday, right? So they are just, I mean, I think not only Mbappe, but the other players, they all are like just coming together as a one group. I think that's why they are such a tough team to beat this time.
Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
Thank you.
Yeah, yeah, it's really cool to see, like, they they're they're none of them are like selfish, really, is is the the cool thing, but...
Okay.
True.
Absolutely. I feel for Portugal because I really want Kris Ronaldo to at least, you know, reach maybe semi, maybe not final, but at least, you know, go deep into the tournament. So we'll see how they perform.
Go on a little bit of a roam.
Yeah, cool. So do you think if Tracy can join us? Do we know?
She said she might be a little bit late. She said she's in a QBR right now.
Okay.
That's nice.
In the meantime, I threw some pictures in of where we sat at at the World Cup game. There you go, they're in the chat.
Well, that'll be great.
Okay, let me...
Yeah, it was, it was crazy. It was crazy.
That looks good.
Nice.
Yeah, we were like, we were like right at midfield, and then they're like, there's the team taking their pick beforehand. There's Mbappe right there, front right. It was awesome.
Evan.
Look, look at the crowd. I mean, look at the crowd. It's like crazy, right? So many people. It's like jam-packed, right? I don't see any seat empty, right?
Yeah.
There was none empty. It was like the World Cup is just, it is the best sporting event. It is awesome, man. It is awesome. I'm a big soccer guy though. I do, I watch the Prem, I watch the English Premier League and everything. So I watched it year round, but the World Cup, there's nothing that compares to it.
Oh.
And weather also looks good that day.
Yep, yep.
It was good then. We it rained on us a little bit at the end of the first half and then in the second half it was gone and it was nice again. So like it almost like hit perfect timing. But yeah, yeah, it was it was sweet. It was sweet. I don't know if I'll ever top that. That was awesome. Awesome experience.
Mhm.
And I can tell you one thing, we have been hearing this, that tickets are not cheap, right?
Kour, no.
I paid, I paid too much for these tickets. I, these tickets were about, they were about 1300 US dollars.
It's pretty extensive.
So yeah, they were pretty expensive, but we weren't going to go, but we were like, you know, it's like all it's on our bucket list. So we were like, let's let's just do it. We were like, let's just pull the trigger. We have a friend that has a girlfriend that lives down in Philadelphia. So we just stayed at her house. She dropped us off at the stadium. So we could we could have a good time didn't have to worry about paying for parking or anything. And it was just
Yeah, it was an awesome experience. But the tickets right now in the knockout stages, forget about it. Forget about it. It's like double, triple, especially where we sat there at the 50, like at the midfield line on the lower tier. Oh my God, you're probably paying 5,000 US to go to that spot, yeah.
Yeah, they're even crazier.
Midfield, yeah.
Wow, crazy money, crazy money, 5000, crazy, yeah, but I...
It really is. And then not to mention, like I can drive to that stadium, but there's people there from all over the world. So they have to get a place to like stay. They have to get a flight, like they have to buy food, like they have to do, like you're spending a ton of money. It's crazy.
Yes.
Exactly.
But here's the thing. So when you are paying so much, you're paying for the experience, right? It's a once in a lifetime thing, right? So people who are watching like World Cup final, it's like a one-time experience, right? So you're paying for the experience, right? That's what it is.
It is.
You are. You are. And it was honestly like, it was worth every penny that we spent. It was such a fun time. Like the fans were so fun. It was so fun to meet people and just like have a good time with the fans. Like, yeah, the World Cup finals in New Jersey, which is like an hour and a half. It's like an hour and a half for me. It's not far at all, but.
Yeah.
That's gonna be crazy.
Unless somebody else wants to buy me tickets, I can't see myself getting into that one.
It'll be good if someone can sponsor, right? That would be nice.
Yeah, right. I'm going to have to talk to Tracy.
Is she going by the way, do you know?
Is she coming to this?
Yeah, I mean, like, not not this, but the finals, will she be there?
Oh, I wish. No, I wish she was. But I have to talk to her and our owner and be like, yeah, maybe you can, maybe you guys can sponsor me. Oh, we're all game side stuff. I promise. Yeah, exactly. I'll hand, I'll hand out like mouse pads and stuff, whatever they want.
No.
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly. You'll be wearing game tight T-shirts, free sponsor going on, right? Yeah.
See, it's a good idea. I mean, it's a great idea. If you can do that, at least Tracy will be definitely in for this when you see, I'll be wearing Gainside t-shirts, Tracy. So it's my free sponsor. We'll be on the TV. We'll be on TV.
Right.
Exactly. Where's...
Where's Lee at? Get him in here. I'm going to pitch the same idea to him. See if IT by Design wants to sponsor me.
Yeah.
Well, that, I mean, if, if, if we can do it, that would be nice, right? You never know.
You better be ready to pay like $10,000 for nosebleed section tickets for me though, that's...
Maybe that that that's a question for Lee. Lee needs to answer that right. Maybe you can you can add me in as well if that if he if he's able to do it and we all can come to US and watch.
I got you. I got you. You'll cover your flight. He covers everything else.
Exactly, all paid expense, right? That's gone, that's the trip.
Mohit.
Exactly.
Just ping Tracy to see how long she's going to be, but if you guys want to get started, you can.
Yeah, the reason we wanted Tracy to be part of this because we just wanted to showcase what and how we're going to proceed going forward. I will be sharing this deck with you, with everyone, this presentation that I'll be showing today. But the idea was if she can join, then I want, it's not.
OK.
We will not take more than like 10 minutes. It's pretty straightforward. We just wanted to showcase that this is what and how we're going to proceed further. That's the thing. By the way, we can continue with our conversation. It's like more interesting. It's more fun to see all the pictures and the experience that you have.
Okay, cool.
Do you also like to like watch basketball, baseball?
I'm a big sports guy. Yeah, my favorites are, I'm a soccer and like an American football fan. American football is like one of my big favorites. Basketball as well, hockey, baseball, I'm not like super into, but still throw it on if it's the only thing.
Mm.
Yeah, baseball, I mean, it's been like almost 18 years that I've been working with American users, and I know that in other culture that Americans, they just love their sport, right? That's the beauty, that's something really like that if you were into sport, then...
It's.
America is the right country because you guys, you support your people like anything, even from the really from the childhood, right? If someone wants to get into basketball, you'll say, okay, play basketball. Stop. Don't worry about studies. Just play, right?
Call.
So, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we get them, get them into it at a young age for sure. Yeah, the NFL, the NFL is getting, they're starting to go like more global too. They're going over to like England for a game or two. They're playing in Brazil this year. So they're making, they're making their rounds. I believe there was a game in Mexico City in Germany.
I.
So, they're starting to like get a little more international, but...
Mhm.
Nice.
Yeah, the NFL and like college football are two that I follow.
Yeah, I don't know if you know this. Yeah, I don't know if you know this, Tyler, but NBA is big in India as well.
Other than soccer.
Really?
So yeah, so I personally am a huge Chicago fan because I used to watch MJ play back in, you know, 90s. So from there on, I'm a huge Chicago Bulls fan. I've been following them from a long, long time. Derrick Rose was one of my favorites as well.
Absolutely.
Yep.
Yeah, yeah, he was awesome.
So, yeah, so I, as I mentioned, that NB is a big, big sport in India, and you'll find a lot of engineers and a lot of, you know, IT guys who are working with American users, they are like into sports, so that's how we...
We just interact and with different states involved, so obviously you get to know how every states, you know, they they work as per their teams involved, like, for example, Philadelphia, 76ers. I know Ellen and I were so right, so you, so...
Yep. Oh, absolutely, baby.
Then you have New York in Knicks winning NBA this year was a big, big deal after I think 50 years, if I'm not wrong. So that's a huge.
It was a big deal. There's a lot of a lot of Knicks fans around here, too. Yeah, yeah, Philly, me and my wife are both 76ers fans, so they've had some tough sledding, but...
Yeah.
Right.
I, I...
Yeah, I still remember in 2007, I purchased this video game NBA 2K. I don't remember it, maybe it's 2K7, something like that. And whenever I used to select 76s, I used to pick Allen Iverson. And then I used to watch Allen Iverson with the, I mean, he just...
Ohh.
Crazy, you know, guy. He's not that tall, but the way he used to, you know, shoot and score, it was just amazing to watch.
No.
Yep. Like create space and all that stuff. Yeah. Yeah. No, he was incredible. He's like our best player ever for sure. I mean, Johal Embiid was really good, but now he's getting a little older. He can't stay healthy. So he's in trouble. Just completely different players too. Like AI was point guard.
Exactly.
Force.
Center, so it's just completely different, but...
Yeah.
For Philadelphia, for 76ers, AI was MJ, right? So whatever. So that every state had their own, you know.
Yes, oh, 100%.
Yep.
I would say superstars, right? But I still, I still remember, I don't know if you remember Jason Williams sent Kings, right? This guy was crazy with his dribbling skills and he used to love watching him, yeah, white chocolate, amazing skills. Yeah, so.
Yep, yep, like legends.
Oh yeah.
Absolutely.
White chocolate.
Yeah, he was really fun to watch. Steve Nash was kind of like very similar kind of play style to him. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, I mean, there was, we saw a bunch of good players growing up. I mean, even like when the Spurs were good. Yeah, Reggie Miller. Yeah.
Yeah, Steve Manish, Suns, Phoenix Suns, right, yeah.
Yeah, Reggie Miller, Reggie, Reggie Miller, I like his three-point shooting pacers.
Yeah.
I still remember it.
I mean, Steph Curry now, like me growing up, like Steph Curry was like the everybody's favorite. Like he was just massive and LeBron, obviously.
Mhm.
So...
I still remember and I was watching this game and someone was saying that nowadays basketball is not basketball what it used to be when MJ was playing because now it's like more of like three-point shooting contest, right? You're not just, you're not attacking the basket, you just...
Yep.
you know, shooting it from way, way behind it, you know, for the three pointer. So it's like three point shooting. Yeah. But I mean, nothing against Steph. I really love this guy to be able to do that. It's again, you know, it's inhuman, I would say, the way he just shoots and it just goes in. So it's like crazy, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, I feel like Steph Curry started that too.
I need you.
Yeah.
Yeah, when he was in his prime, it was like anytime you would see him pull up for a shot, you expected it to go in. But there was like a, there was a running joke in like in the US and just in the NBA community in general that like Steph Curry ruined basketball.
Mm.
Exactly. He, even if you look, they're not wrong because what MJ and these Bulls team was doing at that time, they used to attack the basketball. They used to go in, right? They used to go deep. They were not shooting threes. They were just going deep to score. It was a hard thing to do.
Yeah.
Now, it's like you just need to, you know, just hit the three-pointer, you're good if it goes in.
Yep, move the ball around to create some space and then if somebody gets a decent look, they're chucking a three. Like even on fast breaks now, if it's a fast break, you'll see people pass up layups to kick it out to somebody that's wide open to shoot a three pointer. And it's just, it's just completely different. And yeah, it really is. I think it was more fun like.
Yeah.
No.
Exactly now.
Yeah.
Exactly, it was more fun back then. Exactly. You used to watch so many ankle breaker moves, ankle breaking moves. Now it's like, it's there, but it's not that often. Hey, Tracy, we're just discussing basketball. Hey, we're just discussing NBA.
back in like the early 2000s and stuff.
That's for sure, yeah.
Yeah, you informed me.
Addy.
All right. Sorry for being late. Yeah, we were having a quarterly business review with a customer that ran long for good reasons and not bad. So that's always positive. Yeah.
Yeah, we were talking sports.
No, that's okay. No, that's okay. That's fine.
That's nice. Cool. So at least Tyler and myself, we were able to catch up on soccer, NBA. So I went back. It was just a nostalgic feeling for me, going back to the 90s with MJ, going crazy.
Love to hear that.
Yeah.
Yep. Oh gosh, yes. Those were the days, I'm telling you. And I actually lived in Indiana while all that was going on. So Chicago is a hop, skip, and a jump away. Yeah, so it was a lot of fun.
Mhm.
Jesus.
Lies.
Exactly, you won't believe we just talked about Reggie Miller, right? Indiana Pacers, so...
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Those were the days. Anyways, so welcome everyone, Tracy. Thank you so much for joining, Tyler. Thanks as well. So what we will do today is we just want to showcase.
Those were.
this presentation that we have for you guys. So I'm going to share my screen. Let me know once you see it and I'm going to walk you through.
See ya, that's up.
All right, perfect.
So this will be our weekly service check-in. We also call it weekly business review for last week from June 22nd to 26th. I put in a Gainside logo. If you can send it over to me, I just picked it up from your website. But if you have your own logo, I can put it on this presentation. If that's okay with you.
I just wanted to make sure that it's like more personalized. And obviously partners, they love to see their logo. And that's exactly what we want to make sure that you feel valued. That's the whole purpose behind it. Okay. All right, great. So looking at the agenda items, we'll be going through the executive summary, performance, review, governance.
Yep.
Mhm.
Okay.
Yep.
ITBD service offerings, Build It 2026, BI by Design, US Holiday Schedule, and Way Forward.
Getting into the executive summary, since we started last week, onboarding warm handover not completed. Partner started working on ticket. That's the main highlights from last week. Similarly, we don't have any low lights or any planned activity coming up. But the only help that it requires from your side, Tracy and Tyler.
Yeah.
As per the reporting tool, because from my side I don't have the access. So.
If it's possible, and if you feel like there is no license required, and if you can give me the access, I will be able to monitor how Harper is performing. So it's like, you know, from our side, we'll have an extra eyes to make sure that if you need any help, then we can, you know, quickly.
Support it.
Mhm.
So just to put things into perspective, we do have our partners who have shared read-only access with us. So they have given us the access. We can look at the portal, and then we can check how the engineers are performing. Similarly, if you can do that, I mean, no rush. If you can do that, great. Otherwise, from my side, I will be spending time with Harper.
I.
to review his board, his ticket, just to coach him, guide him, whenever I feel like he needs my help.
Just.
Okay, so any any question?
Yeah, we should be able to do that. I just, no, I just noted that aside though for an action, like an action item for after this, so I'll look into that. We do all of our reporting and stuff like that through Auto Task right now at least, so I think we should be able to get that to you. I'm not sure if it'll take a license or not, honestly, but I'll let you know.
Oh.
Mhm.
Great, thanks. Thanks, Tyler. That will be great. Anything that you want to add before we move on to the next one?
Anything that you want to share maybe which you feel like Harper is doing great. Maybe there's something that he needs to improve on anything because it's just like an open forum, right? We just want you to be vocal.
Ohh.
Yeah, no, fair. I think, I think week one, now that we're a week and a half in, I think I don't have anything that he needs to improve on right now. Like, I think everything's been going very smoothly. He's been asking a lot of good questions, which is a highlight, especially during the onboarding period. He was asking a lot of good questions. He was ready to dive into tickets, like...
Okay.
day one, he was trying to get more tickets, like ready to work them. So yeah, we're just working through like what his workflow looks like now after hours for new tickets and going through some of our older tickets. So he's dove headfirst into that as well. He's very receptive to working on projects that we were articulating for him as well. So.
No lowlights, but those are some highlights and I guess planned activities is one that's a project that we are about to have him work on.
Mhm.
Yeah, absolutely.
Okay.
Absolutely.
Right, cool.
I told Harper that try to see if you can put everything on the time sheet. Like if you're spending 9 hours, just put in nine hours, whatever it is. But then he's like, Kevin, you know, they're not doing it. I said, if they're not doing it, then you start doing it.
Mm.
Yeah.
Mhm.
You know, so he was like, he was like hesitant, so I was just trying to...
Yeah.
Yeah, now that's...
Yeah, no, that's completely fine. I talked to him about like looking into like time sheet stuff on auto task. We like, we don't, yeah, we don't really have time sheets that we we keep right, Tracy, like...
Well...
Rick.
Yeah.
Kip.
Not presently, but there is possibly a move that will be made to doing things like that. Like we, our CEO is tasking us with, as we grow, we need to be able to understand resourcing. And obviously, as we work with you all, we want to
Exactly.
add to the team without that data, it's, you know, we're just kind of guessing. And so he's challenged me with making sure that we're able to at least estimate where people are spending their time. So I think, you know, having a tool like Auto Task, which has that built right into it, we just need to start.
Yeah.
leveraging that. And if Harper, you know, kind of gets the ball rolling, good, perfect. That's great.
Exactly. Yeah, and thank you, Tracy, for sharing this. And I can tell you one thing. We have multiple partners on our side who just live and die by their time sheets. They want everything, every bit of information in the time sheet. You would believe even...
Yeah.
They're ready to, you know, support us telling the engineer, if you don't have work, just mention it. I don't have work. We'll be more than happy to look at it and make changes accordingly, right? If you don't know it, then how we will improve it.
I.
Yeah, so this is...
Mhm.
Exactly.
Right, yeah, that's true. Like, is it more like a, like, are they breaking down like what they're doing for the day? So like, if they work on a project for four hours, they'll put that in. And then if they worked on tickets for, okay, gotcha. Yeah, yeah.
So the idea is to understand how the engineer is spending the entire day, right? And then you start finding anomalies. If you feel like, okay, I feel this is where he could have done better. Or if you look at from a bigger perspective, just imagine if you, if
Mhm.
Yes.
Yeah.
If everyone starts to do it, you will have not weekly, monthly, quarterly, and yearly data with you, and then you can improve to see how and where you want to, you know, have more focus on, as Tracy mentioned about the resource, if my engineer is hitting 80 to 90% utilization every day,
He is being overwhelmed with work. I can see that. And then I can add one more resource. Right? So from resource planning, there are so many things that you can get from the timesheet. I can tell you it has worked, and I think it's going to work for you as well.
Mhm.
Yep, yep.
Yeah, I think.
Yeah, 100% right.
But, but everyone has to, you know, come together.
Yep.
Yeah.
Okay, so moving on, performance review governance, as we have already discussed, we just want to showcase how we are doing as ITBD. We will be showcasing the presentation weekly, monthly, then quarterly, and also discussing our highlights, lowlights,
I love it.
propose any continuum improvement that will be part of this where we can help you to grow, right? We want to share our best practices with you so that Gainsight and ITBD, we all are growing together. Okay? And if we do find any risk and help you to provide mitigation around it, so it's a co-managed environment.
when we are holding each other's hand and moving towards success.
Okay, and today I'm going to share this sample performance analysis slide. This is how we're going to present once we start capturing the data. Okay, so week on week, month on month, we're going to put the data in, and that's how we're going to give you the trend analysis, which will help you.
see how Harper is doing. Okay, so that's the utilization KPI. And the next up is the ticket closure rate. So main KPIs, the major KPIs, we just want to make sure that we show you the trend, that how he has been performing, and if we see any...
Great.
Dip or anything which we can support Harper, then we'll see how we can get it up to, you know.
up to the benchmark wherein he's able to perform and deliver.
Awesome.
Okay, so right now it may not give you the exact picture, but once you start putting in the information, and that's how the data which Harper will be putting in, for example, that weekly and monthly, that will help us to see how he's performing. That's why that data is very important for us to capture.
Gotcha. Okay.
For example, if he's not entering things in the timesheet, then we'll not be able to accurately capture that information. So that piece will be like, you know, it'll be there, but it will not give us the true picture.
Yeah, yep, absolutely. No, I'm not. I'm gonna look into that. I have that set aside as well.
And yep, and every month from our side, you will be getting a CSAT survey. So you get 3 :). One is the positive, the neutral, and the negative one. So as per our services and as per Harper, you can just, you know, rate it. Then once we have that, we're going to showcase it.
As per the presentation, OK.
Perfect. Sounds good.
So for every month, should it go to Tyler you or is it Tracy to whom we should be sending that survey?
Uh, Tyler's closer to uh things, so I would say Tyler.
Okay.
Okay, perfect.
Yeah, I agree.
All right, so moving on, as per the service offering, build it. That's our big event. That's our annual event. So, Tracy, are you coming?
It's in August. I might I might be in Montana at that time.
Yep.
Maybe, maybe Tyler can join us.
So that's kind of a bummer. Yeah, or Kevin.
I was just thinking the same thing. I think, I think that following...
Actually, it's not far from you, right? Talk like, you're not far from Jersey City, are you?
He's in Philadelphia, right?
Now, Jersey City.
I'm like an hour from Philadelphia. Jersey City's probably like 2 hours for me. I think that's that it's either that weekend right after that I go on a fishing trip every year to Lake Ontario though.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, fine.
I have to check the date, but yeah, that's Wake Ontario is probably a little closer actually. Yeah, Jersey City is about two hours from me. So it's not far. Two hour drive.
That could be good.
Okay. And we can, right now we are in a process where we can give you a great deal so Rick can share all the details with you so that, you know, you can register yourself. And if you have any questions, then you can reach out to Rick, myself. We would love to.
first of all, have you on our event and it's a big event wherein you will get the value out of it, that's for sure. This is our 8th year. I wish, the only problem is that the US, they're supposed to give us visa and the visa appointment is a long, long wait.
Okay.
Cool. Are you going?
So you never know, maybe one day I'll be there. Then we're going to watch soccer game together, Tyler. Maybe not soccer, then NBA.
Yeah.
The.
Oh.
That'd be great. That'd be great. We can go to a Sixers game and a Philadelphia Union game.
Right.
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, that would be, that would be nice, but yeah, we we have been trying, so it just that, as I mentioned, the visa time takes it, it's a difficult process in India, so that's the only thing.
Mm.
They don't make it easy, I know.
Yeah, I worked with a younger kid back in my previous employer. He went to college here, so he was here for like school. But he said it was like a, like a 10 to like 14 year wait time or something crazy. I was like, whoa.
And.
Mhm.
What?
Currently, I think it's gonna be close to a couple of years, so it's like it takes time.
Is.
Yes.
Yeah, he said that he said that his parents were all like on the wait list for a long time before they were they were able to like come over here, yeah.
Wow.
Yeah.
Plus, you have to go through a lot of, you know, checks and all, so it's a lengthy process, that's the only, and...
Wow.
Yeah, I might be thinking of like, yeah, full citizen or citizenship, yeah.
Mhm.
It's easy for you to come to India than for us to go to US. That's the thing. But yeah, but Rick, over to you if you want to share anything about Build It.
Yeah, yeah.
For sure.
No, I think you already covered most of the things. I think Lee has already dropped an email to Tyler, Tracy, both of you, I think regarding the event details. So maybe whenever you get time, you can review that. And if any clarity needed, just keep us posted.
Sounds good.
Okay.
Perfect. I think I'm good.
That sounds good to me.
OK, yeah, and next up is Team GPS, so...
Are you using our Team GPS tool?
Not yet.
Not that I'm aware of now.
So are you using like any employee engagement tool on your site?
Yeah, that.
We, our HR system is Gusto.
Um...
Stop, okay.
Again.
But we. Yeah.
So this is like more of a...
combined tool where you are getting the employee engagement, then the meetings can be scheduled, then the rewards in the organizations, then the goals, everything. So Kavan, if you want to showcase quickly, I think the scorecard how you are managing for your engineers.
Yeah.
Give me the Sales page.
Yeah, sales pitch, even though I'm not a sales guy, but that's fine.
Parth.
True.
Is it a is it somewhere to like a?
Is it like a metrics tool and stuff like that too?
So, you'll see it in a sec, so I hope you can see it now.
Sweet.
So it covered everything, your C set, NPS, your client, you know, those surveys can covered here, your employee scorecards, their performance track, then the.
Yup.
Do you have a thing over here?
Yep, so this is kind of scorecard that one of for one of our engineers for Collins engineer that he manages this is showing his quarterly scorecard.
So you can also go ahead with the quarterly, you can also go ahead with the monthly, the weekly, and the daily. It's totally up to you how you design it. Then you also have our social feed wherein you can give recognition to your colleagues. And then as per the points, you can also redeem it. You can get a coup.
Exactly.
Coupons, you're gonna gift card. So all in all, this has so many features which you can, you know, utilize on your side to be able to give more to the employees and also see how team is performing.
Nice.
So for example, you may be having your C set tool, different tool and having HR tool different, but this covers everything in one. You can do the survey part as well. You can do the employment, a C set, client C set, then doing the social feed as well.
Great.
Do you have the performance? The idea is that this is a one-pane and a tool which can help you with everything that you need, as a, as I, yep.
All the engineers.
Yeah, one pane of glass for everything.
Yeah, nice. I like it. That's cool.
Pre.
Rest.
Let me just share my screen back. It has a code on the screen, Tyler Tracy. If you scan this, you can schedule a full demo. Okay.
Mm.
Okay.
Moving on with the holiday schedule, so our next schedule is...
Holiday is July 3rd. So do you need Harper working? Because for him, it will be...
Mhm.
Fort.
Because, because of the time difference, so that'll be 4th, but first of all, I mean, do you need him working on July 3rd?
It wouldn't hurt, right, Tyler? We additional hands.
Okay.
Yeah, I was going to say it wouldn't it wouldn't hurt if he's yeah, if he's available and wants to wants to work that, it wouldn't hurt. It's like a federal holiday here, so I don't think there's going to be much to like, but there's project stuff that he can work on for sure if he wants to get the hours, yeah.
And.
Okay.
Cool.
Yeah, so just for your understanding, as per this holiday schedule, we are supposed to give 10 holidays to our engineers, plus they can pick two optional holidays. On any compulsory holidays, if the engineer works, then we are supposed to give them a compos.
Mhm.
Okay, so for example, if Harper works on July 3rd, then we're supposed to give him a comp of as per, you know, whenever he wants to avail it.
Okay, so just like kind of like a floating holiday or like an 8 hour thing. Okay, okay. Then maybe then maybe we maybe we just have them take the day because I think helped is still like our level ones will still be on for that and I can't foresee it being busy at all.
Yep.
Exactly, yeah.
Kip.
Mm.
Yeah. So I mean, it's totally up to you. You can let me know. You can send me an email if you feel like you need his services. We are okay with him to, you know, work on that day. If you feel like you can work without him, then I would say let him take the day off.
Okay. Yeah, I'll get back to you tomorrow for sure. Or maybe even by the end of today.
Shukla.
End of today is probably fine, yeah.
OK, cool.
Next up is AI by Design. So this year, AI by Design will be part of our Build It. So day 5th is when we will be covering this AI piece. Okay.
So I think you just mentioned regarding Tracy, you were having your QBR. So that's one of our one of our thing in terms of when we were working on building few agents. So whenever we are having our QBR, so getting prepared for every client's QBR is not easy, right? So getting every quarter data, how things went, what's happening there with the client. So.
Mhm.
On our side, we created a QBR agent.
And now that QBR agent is doing everything, getting everything created for our client before our QBR meeting.
So maybe whenever you guys get time, not in hurry, but whenever you feel like we can have a quick demo on those as well.
Interesting.
Okay, sounds good. Tyler and I actually have to hop to another call. But this has been super, super helpful. Lots of great information. We're delighted with Harper so far. He's been great.
Yeah.
Yup.
I was just taking all the time.
Yeah, so I mean, we had just done and the last piece is the way forward. We just want to make sure that Harper remains focused on achieving his KPIs. And as for ITBD, we are committed to deliver the best product and we are ready to support any additional needs that may come up in 2026. All right, so that's pretty much it.
Yeah, perfect.
Perfect.
Excellent.
Awesome.
Now, anything from your side, Tracy, Tyler, if you would like to share any anything from Ryan, any questions, concerns, or feedback for us?
Thank you, everyone. Yeah.
S.
I don't have anything other than what I what I said before about Harper. Everything's been good so far, so yeah, I don't have much right now.
I'm done.
Perfect. Thank you, Tyler. Tracy, anything from your end?
Yes.
Nope. He seems to be humming right along and really fitting into the team and seems like he's eager to learn, which is great.
Awesome. Well, you don't worry. I will be sending a copy of this presentation to both of you. You can do it internally. If you have any questions, you can just feel free to reach out. Okay? But thank you so much for your time today. You have a great day ahead, great evening ahead, and we'll see you next week. Till then, have a good one. Bye-bye.
All right, sounds good.
Awesome.
Me too.
Take care, Team.
Sounds good. Take care, guys.
Bye bye.